no president of the history of our
country has been subjected to such
vicious and disgusting attacks really
but they only attacked me because I
fight for you it's very simple they
can't buy me and they can't control me
and that scares them
beyond belief doesn't really make sense
when you look at the polling but okay
since the very beginning I've shunned
the globalist special interest owners
who have made a fortune off of
destroying our country instead our
presidential campaign has always been
funded by Grassroots Patriots like you
your contribution today will show the
left that nothing can destroy the
greatest political movement in history
yeah so there are people donating to
Trump we we looked at some of that
fundraising data and indeed Trump raised
a pretty penny after the indictment was
announced but isn't he a billionaire
like why why does Trump need to raise
money